got it wrong on the first page big shout
out to anyone who can name that
reference so uh-huh something a little
different with this particular Sundays
Doctor Who I'm gonna take a look at a
Doctor Who comic sort of I don't I I do
read comics I very rarely read movie or
TV show tying or continuation comics
I'll kind of explain why as I go along
and what I'm gonna be reviewing that was
most people would consider like why are
you reviewing that but it sort of gives
me a chance to talk about this kind of
thing in general and it's also my first
sampling of Doctor Who in comic form
because I don't read Doctor Who comedy
so that's not like a matter of principle
but I'll talk about some of the reasons
why I'm usually reluctant to shell out
money for this sort of thing so what I'm
gonna be talking about today is oh boy
wish I got in this in last year and but
noticed when I had the big 2018 eye so
this was from Free Comic Book Day last
year this was sent to me by Alan
Middleton of the relatively geeky
podcast network check it out if you
haven't he's actually it's great stuff
and I'm not only saying that because he
made me is listener of the year for last
year
I mean it helped but that's not the only
reason I'm saying that anyways so what
this is this is very much what you
expect on free comic book day free comic
book day tends to involve things like
what I kind of called zero issues issues
that set up a series but don't really
start the narrative or things like this
which are like little samples of stories
that are going to be continued in the
proper issues and that's what's going on
here this has actually got three stories
in it despite only being how many pages
is this thing hang on I should have
checked that before um well they're not
numbered and I'm not going to
it's about your average comic book
length but there's three stories in here
and despite the doctors on the cover
what we have officially is a Tenth
Doctor story a seventh doctor story and
an eleventh doctor story I say story
they are very short they're you know
they're about their five pages each so
we're looking at about 20 pages all
together and each of them ends with a
sort of continued in and then it gives a
specific title that you could you could
pick up and buy or sometimes it's just a
generic the adventure continues this
November which at the time meant that
was when new Doctor Who episodes started
airing so all three of these have
different writing and art credits I'm
not going to go through all them you can
look up the writing credits on these if
it matters that much to you so I'll talk
about each of these individually and as
I do it'll sort of give me the chance to
discuss this kind of thing in general so
the first one is a attempt doctor story
called catch a falling star
now catch a falling star is actually
kind of narrated by a companion who I've
never heard of now I don't know if this
is a character who has actually appeared
in the comics because I I mean I know
from Big Finish that sometimes the
ancillary material have their own unique
companions that they use sometimes
because like you know Big Finish does
that a lot you know the Eighth Doctor s
Charlie and Sixth Doctor has evil and
Smythe and yeah there's very more
besides that but you know just as a few
examples so I don't know if this
character of Gaby Gaby Gonzalez I don't
know if she's like that or not because
I'm not gonna do research I'm allergic
to research I have a note for my doctor
but what I can tell you is that this
sampling it feels like kind of a
backstory on her because it's narrated
by her
sort of giving and it's not really I say
narrated by her it's not really telling
a story it's it's her sort of thoughts
about how she got where she is as she
believes she's going to die
so she's literally falling through space
as she's thinking of this she's thinking
of meeting the doctor for the first time
the tenth doctor in this case she's you
know we get little flashes of the
different things they run into the
different monsters and whatnot we get a
really cool page from her sketchbook
which I guess is kind of her thing that
she sketches the monsters and the
adventures that they have which I
actually he's a really cool conceit I'm
kind of surprised that we haven't had
more campaigns kind of into keeping a
record I mean we've got River with her
diary but like this sort of thing like
the idea of keeping a sketchbook that's
a really neat idea that again I'm really
surprised hasn't happened up to up to
now and in like in the show proper and
it sort of leads up to her you know her
being in the situation she is basically
floating in space waiting to die until
she wakes up on the interior of the
TARDIS and having been caught by not the
Tenth Doctor
but the 12th where we had the Peter
Capaldi doctor embracing her and saying
I told you if you had ever fall I'd
catch you and it's a nice moment the
whole thing's just really sweet and I
really like the impression of Gaby that
we get so again I don't know she appears
in the comics outside of this I kind of
hope so
cuz like just in these five pages I
really liked her I thought she was a
really good character and so then we get
to the Seventh Doctor story and that's
called the Armageddon gambit and this
one we come in basically I was gonna say
in the middle with really stale end of a
battle where we have the Seventh Doctor
and ace and they are you know coming in
basically luring out these warmongering
aliens out to the open where the faction
that they were fighting with can capture
them and basically end the conflict more
or less peacefully and then it ends with
with the doctor and ace heading off to
deal with something specific and that
one that one is actually cited to to
continue in a specific Seventh Doctor
adventure called Operation volcano so
that one does specifically lead into
something else and then it ends with
midnight feast which is 11th doctor and
this one is the most sort of just a lark
kind of episode because he's he shows up
in this woman's kitchen a woman named
Alice again I don't know if she's like
Gabby and like you need two comics or if
it's just someone we've never met before
and it's just implied though this is
someone who's just dealt with the doctor
before because she's very unfazed by him
he's just said he's raiding her cabinets
because he he wanted a midnight snack
and he's not finding anything so he goes
off to this intergalactic diner where
the first thing he does is talk a couple
of aliens who are about to start a war
over which one of them gets a booth
he talks them into calming down and
sharing a Knickerbocker glory which is a
type of ice cream and then you know he
tries a whole bunch think starting with
fish fingers and custard nothing is is
quite hitting the spot he ends up back
and analysis kitchen and where she's
just making yourself a tuna sandwich
which he tries means like no that's
exactly what I needed and it feels very
eleventh the doctor in that way but it's
it's easily my least favorite of the
three I've partly because of how in
substantial it is and that's an odd
criticism to level it any of these
stories because they're insubstantial by
design but even by that measure it's
really insubstantial and also it just
does something that bugs me which is
that and now I mean that I've talked
about this before so I won't dwell on it
much but it's got the doctor you know
the way that he talks down these two
aliens who are about to start a war over
getting a booth which is I think is a
fun idea is he basically just says I'm
the doctor and they're like the doctor
haha god sake
you know his whole banking on his
reputation and how often that was done
especially during Elevens run really did
hurt me by the time that what that was
over I was I'm really really over it so
like they there's that as far as the
other to go like you said the first ones
the best one I think the one with with
the Seventh Doctor and Ace is cute it
works pretty well but the sort of
talking about some of the stuff that
tends to bug me about this largely my
hang-up with these kinds of products
these sorts of continuations of
live-action TV shows and comics usually
comes down to art because whenever comic
book artists are being called upon to
recreate real life people the results
tend to not work for me in general by
and large especially with characters
like with real distinctive general looks
like the doctor tends to have I really
wish they would go more stylized and not
trying to reference the real actor as
much as it's very obvious they do
because I think you end up with a couple
of different results you end up with
this sort of you can end up with a sort
of uncanny valley effect where it's like
it's to reference like you're trying too
hard to look and it's like you've
obviously pulled from a specific shot of
this person and like I'm not even sure
that works for the moment that's the one
thing you can end up with or the other
thing is like they're trying so hard to
recreate this face that you just end up
with things that look we
that's like if you weren't trying to
make this look like a real person you
never would have made that expression or
use that angle or whatever it just it
tends to really look off-putting and or
it doesn't happen in these comics but
the of the other extreme flipside of
that is that the is that the the
characters just flat-out don't look like
the actors like you can't identify them
by it like I remember trying to pick up
the first trade of the comic book that
continued angel after that show ended
and I really like the story anyway but I
would turn pages and characters would
turn up and everyone would be like oh
and I'd be like I'm sure I'm supposed to
recognize this person on site but I
can't I have no clue that's supposed to
be now that's not the case with with
this but it is bordering on that uncanny
valley thing especially in the Seventh
Doctor story and and that's the other
thing that sort of sinks the eleventh
Archer story for me is is the look of
him specifically and again I really
think it is a problem that comes up when
depicting real people because I can
compare Alice to the eleventh Doctor
Alice looks way better like as a
character and it's just it's just one of
those things that happens and it can
really pull me out of stories which
again is a shame because none of these
are bad they're all you know there's a
there's a best a decent dinner the week
one but even the week one as far as the
story goes it's fine like I will it
would have any of these would have been
you know perfectly acceptable as you
know little minisodes
you know sort of things bridging
episodes or or what-have-you
you know things like pond life or or you
know space and time and whatnot
things like that any one of these would
have fit that just fine I don't know if
I'll ever cover Doctor Who comics
well I'll back up
right now I have no intention of
purchasing Doctor Who comics because I
have no idea where I'd begin if I were
gonna even try and do that I mean if
anyone wants to try and force my hand
like Alan did and send me stuff
maybe PL boxes in the description
I am shameless these days patreon links
down there too
ok maybe that's my clue that I should be
headed into the tail end I mean this was
just kind of a fun thing for me to do
because that's been sitting on my shelf
for obviously months at this point so I
was overdue to you know crack it open
and then once I did I kind of wanted to
talk about it so there you go Doctor Who
2018 ya lazy bugger umm 2018 Free Comic
Book Day sample story thing did you see
it what did you think about it if you
did or if you didn't probably a more
interesting question would be what are
your thoughts on Doctor Who comics in
general do you have a particular run a
particular doctor that you think has
worked better in comics whatever your
thoughts on any of that are drop them
down in the comments let's talk about it
I mentioned there's stuff down there so
check it out there's stuff I didn't even
mention this down there to give it a
look if you don't want to look at it or
click on any of it that is okay too
because at the end of the day you're the
counsel um I just run the meetings and
until next time this counsel is
adjourned
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]